Nation of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan
has hung out with countless Democratic
Party big shots including Barack Obama
once upon a time he's also spent decades
spewing a hateful rhetoric to anybody
who'll listen to him your country has
been taken from you by the synagogue of
sake if you come to take our life don't
be surprised if you lose your own fair
come on get an army to kill white people
because you see white people deserve to
die yeah why people deserve to die
thanks for that useful tip Victor Davis
Hanson is a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution congressman Todd Rokita from
Indiana has just introduced a resolution
in the house to condemn Farrakhan
congressman as far as this resolution is
concerned Keith Ellison from Minnesota
for example who's one of Farrakhan's
closest congressional allies says this
whole thing is going nowhere
nobody cares about Farrakhan and he can
get along with cozying up to Farrakhan
as much as he wants
well that's it's complete hypocrisy mark
you've pointed that out dr. Hansen has
pointed it out this news organization
has pointed out you know but where's the
rest of the media this liberal media
elite that lets all this go by you know
if this happened to a Republican you
know if there was a meeting like this
you we wouldn't last one day in office
and all the news media would cover it
from now until the election and beyond
and it's absolutely ridiculous that this
is being covered up and that's why I
introduced it's one of the reasons I
introduced the resolution no and and
when you talk when when they talk about
David Duke David dukes got three
followers one of which is his dog
where's Farrakhan has huge popularity
with Nadja not just with the black
community but also at high levels of the
Democrat Party Victor what's odd to me
is that Farrakhan seemed to go away for
a long time he seemed like something to
do with the Million Man March which is
20 years ago
and he seemed mired in the past and then
suddenly you find out the women's March
which are the coolest people around at
the moment they protest Trump they wear
the pink hats and all the leaders of the
women's March as somehow plugged into
Farrakhan he's kind of still current
isn't he
it is funny because we've known for
three decades that he'd espouse racism
and anti-semitism so the question is why
at 84 does he have this new apocalyptic
language that he didn't just say that
express racism he said that you used
terms like going down and is over 73
years after the Holocaust he says that
era the Jew is over and the answer is
that in this transformation from the
Democratic Party of old to the new
identity politics progressive party he's
useful he's not an albatross around
somebody's neck but he's in that he's a
you useful asset and you can really see
that you mentioned the women's March
miss Perez and so sore Malorie but gosh
when Danny Davis think about that a
congressman says that nobody cares about
Farrakhan and he used the word the
Jewish Question that was a 19th century
you know debate anti-semitic debate in
Europe about the proper place of view of
the Jews but in the hands of the Third
Reich this will called udin Fraga the
Judt
Jewish Question was a euphemism of the
Holocaust and you have a congressman
talking about the Jewish Question in
2018 it's absurd and it just reflects
that you mentioned Barack Obama's
photo-op but even more interesting the
photographer who took that was
bewildered because he said I don't know
why they wanted to suppress it was
common knowledge that Nation of Islam
people worked on the Senate campaign
well you know it's it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous that I even have to ever
introduce this resolution it's an easy
question do you can do you condemn
anti-semitism and the modern Democratic
Party as the dr. points out can't answer
the question
right I mean Victor what what's it seems
to be a byproduct of identity politics
that what matters is who you are so that
if a white man
says this kind of stuff he's alright
he's part of the problem at
Charlottesville Trump is called on to
denounce him if if Farrakhan says this
he can say exactly the same things and
Farah Khan's identity absolves him
entirely from it it does it's very scary
because in the case of the women's March
we have AB laughs ricchan American woman
we have a Hispanic woman we have an Arab
American woman and they all feel that
they get special dispensation to collude
with somebody who's an obvious race
racist and anti-semite and the members
of the Black Caucus who remember Obama's
photo op took place in the capital us in
the basement of us happily so people
they feel that they're completely exempt
to either collude with or to support or
to dismiss as racism and it's going to
create it just creates this problem of
cynicism and that nobody really does
believe them anymore because the real
question is what is their agenda do they
agree with Farrakhan or they not agree
with and they just need to tell us and
that's why I really applaud the
congressman's effort we need to ask them
that question no white white people
deserve to die you can't really get any
more specific than that
professor congressman thanks very much
for joining us tonight